jerry jones cowboys owner and general
manager having someone and that's his
daughter charlotte jones anderson hold
the cell phone for him that's probably a
granddaughter holding the cell phone for
jerry jones during the draft itself
that's a pretty sweet gig if you can get
it holding jerry jones cell phone not to
be confused with cleaning jerry jones
glasses which we saw
during a game eight years ago so let's
start this game of would you rather
chris with a very simple question would
you rather be the person holding jerry
jones cell phone during the draft or the
person cleaning his glasses during a
game
uh i think i'd rather clean his glasses
because you know you clean the glasses
it's just a quick quick wipe off and
then you give them back like hey the
cell phone you got to sit there hold it
you don't know how long that
conversation is going to last your arm's
going to get tired that one i'd rather
be the glasses cleaner there i'll do
whatever he wants he gives me a room in
that boat i'll come down there and hold
the phone and clean the glasses go ahead
see that's the key i'm leaning toward
holding the cell phone because it
happened on the yacht i mean i've been
to a football stadium that's where the
glasses are cleaned i don't care about
that put me on the yacht and i'll hold
the cell phone the only problem is yeah
and you know you hold the cell phone
long enough while he's talking you may
you know you may get a little food
flying your direction and we're you know
you're within the six foot buffer zone i
don't know that that's the most hygienic
approach right now but you're on the
boat and the boat by all indications uh
all images we've seen all stories i've
heard is absolutely positively
spectacular so uh if cell phone duty
includes being on the boat give me the
holding the cell phone dude any day of
the week all right uh more importantly
if you're jordan love and now we're
moving on to the series would you rather
topics would you rather have aaron
rodgers take you under his wing for two
years
uh or would you rather he force his way
out of town
sooner rather than later so you can play
i'm gonna go with option one and that
aaron rodgers takes me under his wing
for two years you know what you know
first off
it's not easy coming in the nfl as a
rookie you know it's a whirlwind as we
heard brian flores says there's so much
to learn you're moving your whole life
you're trying to meet all these new
people and you know show the
organization that you're worth the
number one pick or whatever it may be
and it is good to have somebody there to
show you how it's done you know even in
my you know when i was young we had brad
johnson there it was great i got to
follow brad's lead and okay this is what
a pro does daily this is his routine and
then i can make my own routine off of it
so i think there's a lot of great from
that especially learning from a great
one like rogers plus jordan love if you
talk to anybody or watch the film is
very raw i think if he got thrown out
there right now this year it could be
bad to where it could overwhelm you know
overwhelm you with badness to where it
could ruin his career he needs this time
to
sit back and learn a little football and
grow his knowledge of the game
i just have a hard time envisioning
aaron rodgers taking any other
quarterback who aspires to replace him
eventually or sooner under his wing i
just don't see that and look the the
only the only benefit and i think we
mentioned this yesterday is that if he
does take jordan love under his wing and
teaches jordan lung uh jordan love how
to get ready sooner rather than later
that enhances the timetable for rogers
to get out of there he's doing himself a
favor if he's decided he wants out he
helps get jordan love ready so he can
get out and the sooner love is ready the
sooner he gets out but i just especially
after his own experience i mean you
could say that because brett favre
treated him like crap that aaron rodgers
is going to do it differently i don't
think that's the way the human animal
works otherwise hazing would end at some
point right hazing in any organization
happens because people who were new got
hazed so then when someone new comes
along they haze them and it's a cycle
that never ends so uh i i think that
that aaron is gonna be more inclined to
treat jordan love the way aaron got
treated back in 2005. all right if
you're tuatanga viloa would you rather
have
andrew luck's career great but short or
alex smith's career up and down but 15
years in and still going
wow that's a good one um
i think i'd rather have andrew luck's
career you know both made a boatload of
money so we know that and so i'm not
going to really get into that they both
can live comfortable no matter what they
do
uh but i look at it like this i mean
first off andrew luck came into the nfl
carrying a team on his back almost from
the get-go and what do they do go to the
playoffs for four years in a row yeah
albeit it might be short there for
uh andrew luck and company i just guess
i would look at it where i would rather
be have a short career where i was
talked about in a way where i was one of
the best quarterbacks in football and in
the top five you know pretty much
regularly through my career when i was
healthy as compared to alex smith who's
you know i think consistently kind of
been in the middle of the league as far
as starting quarterbacks are concerned
well for me the bottom line is quite
often the bottom line andrew luck made
97.1 million alex smith is at 161
million and counting with that big of a
spread
give me the big mamu i'll take alex
smith and i'll take that money now now
now uh the the espn
uh
well i don't know what it is e60 i get
all those to 30 for 30. i don't know
what the the the the you know the
tagline of it is but yeah right the
documentary focusing on alex smith's
horrific leg injury and recovery is
coming up i may feel differently after i
see that because he almost died from it
so if that's part of it i don't know
that i want it but if we're just looking
at football career and we're looking at
earnings i'm taking the alex smith 160
million over the uh the andrew luck 97.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports